okay hello everyone welcome to another
orphan language design review part of
our incremental language development uh
series and we have a variety of topics
here
first topic a round and Min and
numerical order
so
I guess the question here is
what should men do with an around right
A Min of an interval is the lower limit
of the interval correct
interval is different
of centered interval it's the value of
all minimums over all elements of all
intervals
so the standard thing that we do for
evaluation of a numeric function of
Center intervalues that we give an
interval containing all values of the
function
so for the function means we give an
interval that contains
interval of for example five comma 1.
is that okay so if I say men of that
if you get me mean of two intervals
okay I see men of
let's say centered interval here comma
and then let's say centered interval six
comma three
right and that's the interval that
contains all the means of two elements
where the first element is in the first
interval and second element is in the
second interval
I'm a little confused so a sentence
interval if I look at the distribution
of possible values that the number could
have in the case of the first one five
plus minus one it ranges from four to
six is that correct yes yes
and the second one ranges from three to
nine
yes so how the heck does it get uh Min
it is not why isn't that min
yeah so the mean the lowest mean that
you can get is then three
right and why does it have any centered
interval stuff I mean isn't the Min just
like what's this it's the set it's the
set of all mins you get where you take
one element from the first interval and
one element from the second so the
highest Min you can get is six
right if you I see
if it because that was the thing that
you got
no what is that that's the top of the
first interval or what top of the first
interval yeah so it's the
lower bottom and higher and lower top
that's what you will get
there is a graphical example of this
particular case in the next section okay
if you scroll down
you see so there you are taking the mean
of the yellow and blue intervals and you
get the green interval
so it's from from the lower bottom to
the lower top
I see
so that means
okay so you the the true data so to
speak lies somewhere in the yellow
interval and somewhere in the blue
interval
and you're saying given all possible two
datas
yeah okay I understand I think the logic
of this okay
I think this is consistent with how
Center interval works the important
conclusion from here is that mean of two
objects doesn't have to be one of those
two objects
I think that's important let's do that
is an important lesson
it's a little bit bizarre but it's an
important lesson I mean just like men of
a single interval isn't an interval
men of an interval right it's just a a
pure number if I'm not mistaken
yes yes
so for his historical reason actually so
so do you think that's wrong uh so if we
if we consider mean a numeric function
as it is
and what the what interval arithmetic is
supposed to do for a numeric function
then it's wrong
oh gosh
I wouldn't call it wrong I think it's
it's different approach well if you know
science if you do sign of interval you
got an interval if you do mean of
interval and mini is a numeric function
just like sine you get a number that's
somewhat strange
yeah okay all right anyway but but our
topic today is around exactly so so
around sits in between intervals numbers
and distributions and and this
discussion is to show that these
different approaches have different
opinions on what to do
okay and so
I tend to believe that numbers is the
most important precedent to follow here
and and I think this idea of mean of
several arounds returning one of them
rather than a new one that wasn't there
is something that users will expect
what did Sanders suggest
so
Sandra's suggestion is to return one of
them and to decide in based on some sort
of tolerance so because together with
what to return there is the question of
of order right so so we have to separate
the question of numerical order from the
question of mean
the numerical order is easier because we
can just
return true false or one zero
and so
there are two main choices one is do we
consider overlapping do we consider a
tolerance like equal does or do we just
go straight to the centers
all right wait a minute so the issue is
you've got a bunch of around they
effectively overlap in the way that this
one does for example exactly and
one thing we could do is just say
I mean there's several different
approaches we could take the look at the
centers
take the smallest Center just return
that
now I mean
presumably okay this is only relevant in
the one-dimensional case anyway because
Min is a one-dimensional story are there
analogs of men that we have to worry
about like ranked men and so on
that are more complicated stories or if
we nail men or we automatically get
these other things sort of
philosophically nailed
I think that the the first thing to nail
is numerical order and the mean can be
based on numerical order once we decide
the sort of thing we were discussing
with Adam do we return another
one of the objects that was there some
sort of constructed new object
but that's a separate thing
okay
um
Sanders comment on a live stream is the
thing is that they always overlap that
the rounds always overlap because
they're Tails they're animals with
infinite tails oops
yes but but the tail Decay is very fast
so there are cases in which things are
clear
no because presumably there's a case
where you know you're far enough on the
tail that it's it's sort of the the
probability of them overlapping is like
the well yeah there's really some
analogies to equal right where because
equal also has you know approximate
stuff right right which is the statement
this could be treated like numbers and
like Precision of numbers
um
but okay let me ask another question
what about asymmetric intervals
asymmetric arounds I mean what you're
showing here
clearly if they're symmetric arounds
there is an ordering that can be defined
by their Maxima AKA their means right
yep if they're asymmetric that's less
obvious and then one starts worrying
about you know should one think about
the integrals or what should one do
I still think the center is the
preferred value even if they are
asymmetric because that's I mean when
you suppress and
an asymmetric around you are still
thinking that the center is the value
the most probable value
yes
okay but if you've got if you're
comparing two things
and I mean can somebody make up a
version of this where it really has most
of its support the one who who has the
the center to the right has most of its
support
somehow to the left of another one
can't that happen
um yes
so so for example if you go up a bit and
change the definitions
of the ransom okay so create a two
around one sematic one asymmetric
okay
so do a a equals
okay hold on a a equals a round of what
um four comma one we can keep that one
and then a b could be
around the five list
um one comma three
and now evaluate that plot
so that's the heck is that so that's the
sort of thing we are so
down here what happened here
well that's what it does yeah so what
this represents is an around in which
the the probability is still half a
gaussians one to one side one to the
other one
I didn't know I did that I thought it I
thought it somehow
well I didn't really think about it I
thought it has some kind of distribution
with some kind of ketosis thing or
something I didn't really think about it
I didn't realize that was the district
that it was a piecewise distribution
like that
okay
well so
that's still has the feature
yeah I mean so that didn't affect
it's not the picture that I thought I
was going to see here so
okay I understand so this is a way of
still having gaussians so that we can do
all computations
yeah right right so the question is if
you if you say say a b is equal five and
then
make the left bound really large and the
right boundary really small then it will
look like the center will be to the
right of the first center but but
actually most of the distribution will
be smaller than the first one okay hold
on tell me what that is to put in here
uh 10 comma 100
something like that
so the
that is
okay I think the asymmetic cases is
comes later we should
decide what to do with the center case
there is half the probability still to
each side
yes
right
okay
what does what happens does anybody know
your average physics situation
what do people actually do
they say I've got this number in this
number and I take the Min of those two
numbers what do they actually do
I pull down my um
uh
gosh this is getting very long in the
tooth these days the um
handy little physicist
um
zero dear I've only got ones from
1994. hmm well I'm sure this hasn't
changed much okay particle physics you
know information booklet has sort of
practical
no look statistics have got a whole
section on that but I wonder whether
they talk about I mean what would you
expect them to say if anything or will
they not say anything
well the question is not very well posed
if you don't specify more things like to
some confidence levels and things like
that
yeah
so so
that's an alternative here to impose
some sort of threshold
above which we are sure of things and
Below we just return unevaluated or
it's a bit what interval does right so
if if you try to compare two overlapping
intervals yeah so so interval actually
has 100 threshold meaning if there are
disjointance under order then they are
ordered if they inter overlapped and
then we return unevaluated
right sorry say that again if if what
when the so so if intervals are
completely disjoined they are ordered if
they overlap that then the order
function return unevaluated yeah but but
this the disjoint property depends on
setting a confidence level here here
yeah here around you you would need the
confidence level in intervals they are
sort of sharp things and and bounded all
right so look what are our options here
I mean
what is there is there a preferred
proposal for what to do I think so I
think
my proposal here is to judge by centers
and then have a separate function or
several separate functions that take
confidence levels
and so if you want configure levels you
have to go to a more powerful function
right and I'm and you know I'm not you
know if you have
you know 1.0
you know plus or minus
1 and 1.1 plus or minus 10. I'm not sure
that's saying that the first one is less
than the second is is such an
improvement
for numbers so numbers have a threshold
they have some seven bits of Tolerance
and you have to go through those
thresholds in order to to accept things
what was this thing with accomplishment
supposed to look like
do you have a specific proposal here for
what that function would be so it would
be something like uh it thinks the
distributions have to overlap more or
less than
such number and we can impose 70 75
percent has been suggested by sander we
could use 95 to be more in
yeah physicists use
well okay
would this become an option to numerical
order or what
I think we would need separate functions
in the same way that we have things like
vector less we could have an around list
that takes another parameter oh gosh
right and and right numerical order
can't return unevaluated
right I mean the less an equal could
take tolerance you know could have an
implicit tolerance
um numerical order that cannot but it
can return zero when it doesn't know
what to do it effectively it's like
considering that they are equal
right which is
yeah well
yeah uh right it's Sub Zero right zero
is supposed to mean that they're
equivalent not that they're
incomparable
what are we doing right now with around
with um what does the code do right now
does it do something sensible does it do
something crazy no around basically
either return unevaluated or if it
returns something is because some
general functions by coincidence do
something
so I think in this case effectively it's
just comparing the centers
but this is what you're proposing doing
in general exactly yeah
right but but that that that's an
accident of the fact that Min has the
numeric function attribute
and you know I'm not sure like I said
right if that's you know if that's 1.0
comma one and you know
1.1 comma
you know
2.3 I'm not sure that
you know returning the first one is
really
well that's what Jose is proposing this
is that I I understand that that's what
he's proposing and I'm saying I I don't
agree with that proposal well okay so do
you have a different proposal
um
I think a different possibility would be
to to have uh Center for for the result
to be expected value of center of of uh
of the minimum and the error to be
standard deviation of the minimum we
can't compute it symbolically but we
possibly would be able to approximate it
yeah a question I have is whether or not
around is built on the Assumption of
gaussian distributions or it doesn't
even specify a distribution
it will work it is doing the simplified
math that is possible because it's
assumed that everything is gaussian
of course we now realizing piecewise
gaussian so if it assumes gaussian or
piecewise gaussian
then we can do confidence levels
and the thing I remember from undergrad
physics lessons is that the three sigma
limit is basically what they consider to
be decidably different
yeah
but so what I mean so what's your point
then I mean that that if it's if the two
arounds differ by well I mean that's
another question
is
if we assume that we really are treating
these as gaussians
then there are functions we can imagine
that ask
you know questions like
at the three sigma level are these two
arounds different
yeah but three sigma is pretty strict
but whatever who cares one Sigma
whatever it is it doesn't matter but I
mean in
and that's just confusing the integral
of those distributions but I mean
what is the question that okay
the first thing seems to me like
anybody who is relying on the men of
tour rounds it sounds to me like the
definitions are sufficiently fuzzy that
if you're relying on that
I'm just
I don't know I mean it depends on what
the meaning of the thing is if the
meaning of the thing is this around is
representing a large number of
experimental observations that you are
summarizing with us around
yes and you've got two different arounds
that both correspond to large numbers of
observations then you take the Min of
those two
then you would expect something that
takes the men of individual observations
much like we're doing in central
interval
well okay but it's I do you have a
different proposal
well I mean my you know my proposal is
that you know men should be like less
and and just return unevaluated and you
know if we want to say that if it's at a
certain Sigma level we we resolve then
great but well then we'd have to have an
option to control that wouldn't we but
how does less do that less doesn't have
such an option
correct
there's another possibility that's
completely different which is that if
you have a distribution in a confidence
level the minimum of the diff
distribution at that con Fitness level
just gives you the mean value
minus whatever with a lower bound on the
confidence level
so if you say that you had four or one
the men of around 4 1 could possibly be
three
yeah but that's the same thing that's
something similar to what interval does
which we're not even sure we like
yeah but I mean the reason I would
suggest that is because if you have
around four and one and around five and
three you can create a joint probability
distribution from those two different
things which I don't think would really
be in a round no it isn't that's the
whole point it's not on a round I mean
centered interval has that feature that
it's doing these joint effects over this
joint distribution thing yeah
so I think I'm comparing with numbers
and numbers always return something with
numerical order and mean less Etc
and and and they judge by the centers
I I added an example in chat
to compare our rounds with numbers
Sandra is commenting on the weirdness of
this
if that doesn't evaluate
which I think is
fine
right and this is why I'm saying that
this is this is an accident of
implementation of the fact that men has
the numeric function attribute if men
did not have the numeric function
attribute this would not happen
and but was that Min is should be made
more like less and Jose is saying that
uh
more like uh more like men and you know
in particular my example is you know
suppose it's you know rather than the
two having a one there it's a two and a
five
um
so I
the fact that those two are
different happens with interval already
so it's not that weird
and I think my point is that people are
going to expect that when they do
computations with around it's like
numbers they always work if we start to
return things unevaluated
all computations will get stuck at some
point I kind of agree but then we've got
that less sub at the top there what do
we think should happen with that less
let me give you an example okay which is
going to get fairly silly if we say this
and then this says a round of a hundred
comma one I think that's fairly silly
uh just enter that should return true
right yeah yeah
right but suppose that's a hundred comma
200.
no this is where we're getting Brad's
you know kind of criteria if it's a
hundred comma 30 that's no 100 200 we
don't even worry about that a hundred we
don't worry about it we gotta do
something 100 well 150 is already a
problem though or 130 is already a
problem
because three three times thirty is
ninety okay so that one
but I mean
we either have to decide as we're doing
with less
that there's some numerical fuzz we're
deciding
We could decide on default you know
confidence interval here
well can I ask another question
yeah men usually when I've used it just
returns a number if it's just returns a
number then numeric order follows as a
consequence of that pretty easily but
what the proposal is here to return from
Min a number plus possibly a confidence
interval so is that what we want or is
there a way to make the input to min
have a strict output of being just a
number
sorry when you see a number we are
talking about numbers with finite
precision and then this these problems
appear there too right because you may
have two very very unprecise numbers
right
by having things like less just
magically use some particular tolerance
level right exactly
but but that tolerance level is
typically also joined to to the idea of
using the centers to decide
that's why adding numbers so if you have
a very complicated
case with around that number and we see
what the correspondent numbers will do
yeah
and my point is that they always resolve
to something
they never return unevaluated
okay
look at an example of men with bad
Precision numbers
yes that's an that's a case do you have
before you see in which the 401 and 405
comma three
those two are going to overlap
comma one
and N is this what you're saying no two
lines before a below sorry
so I think he's saying that that number
thing will convert year round to a
number with low Precision exactly oh
right except that that's
um
oh yeah sorry I'm a little bit slow on
following year
it's a
so those two numbers although I mean
that that
so that's the first one
that's right
and you can you can have them closer
together so change the 405 to 401 for
example
so they totally overlap
yeah I understand
that's the basic point is okay so look
there's a default behavior that we can
have with a round it's you know we
should make it be as sensible as
possible and but there's clearly many
possibilities here
as Sandra is commenting and I was going
to basically say the same thing
we need some more
Persnickety way to deal with this
in which
you get to explicitly specify confidence
intervals and things like this
because I think without that
I mean potentially then we can even do
that with actual distributions we can
say
I mean I don't even understand what
happens if we say
you know if we say men of X comma y x is
distributed
like I I don't know exactly how this
would be work but if I say Min of X Y
how do I do this do I do say
distribution I'm trying to do this with
this x is transformed transform
distribution
okay of this and then X is distributed
so it's escape this Escape
and you put the distribution here
so normal with normal distribution with
some numbers
okay let's pick numbers here okay so
let's say this is now going to be 2
comma two
now how do I plot this can I say PDF of
this
yes you can upload PDF on that
but here we will all that need to be a
part 3D we would need perhaps
parameters
X
not plot 3D it's just this right because
why is it taking forever
these computations are hard integrals
for various points integral for each
point yeah why doesn't it compute the
integral once and then cache it
if you compute PDF first and then plot
then yes
in the plot function everything is
computed for each X in the cloud points
we should figure out how to Cache those
things now that we have compiler
technology that we have we kind of know
when
magnificent
I don't know what this is showing us
particularly but I mean if I if I make
these distributions
what should I be doing here I make this
one so I think this is supporting Adam's
idea that the result is another round
with a computed Center and computer
computed um yeah because I mean if I how
do I find the maximum of that situation
yeah yeah mode or
how do I how do I compute can I compute
the dominance
if if that is not a gaussian then it may
be breaking some assumptions about
around
or mean of the transform distribution
expectation will find the
um
well you need to especially you cannot
compute the just the expectation of PDF
expectation works on the variables in
the specified distribution
so it would have to be that uh
distribution not PDF yeah like that
no no
it doesn't understand that as a function
you would have to multiply so that would
be the integral
um integrate x times the percent free
free 18x and that would compute the
expectation or or to just put in the the
transform the solution there I'll put
the transform distribution here
no no that would the integration that
worked that way
how do I do it I've got the transform
distribution so okay so expectation X
comma X distributed as the transform
distribution
couldn't you also just say mean of the
transform distribution yes you could say
the mean as well yes yeah it's it's
probably completing the exact value if
you if you make it somewhere in exactly
it will hopefully be faster yes so the
the it fails to compute the formula for
symbolic I mean and and means and
standard deviation so
um an expectation or
you know if you put to put hand in front
and then it's gonna go numerically it
might be faster okay
okay so that expectation value which is
not the maximum
no I mean
close to because it's a unimodal
distribution
right okay listen guys we clearly need
to have something okay
point one I suspect there is a Criterion
for a round that is some kind of Sigma
based Criterion that we can use to
decide whether we evaluate around less
than around so to speak
just like we use the Fairly arbitrary
thing for numbers with less which is
frankly served us well over the last
three decades or whatever you know that
was a Criterion put in at the very
beginning hasn't been changed it doesn't
come back to bite one very often
um
then I think we need a much more precise
thing that
can take around treated as gaussians
and can decide
I mean then
what we want is a bunch of
I see it's a bunch of results of these
kind of piecewise functions
hmm
I don't even know what would happen if
we have piecewise for example which is
asking for you know is the value in this
range in this range in this range with
the rounds
so we can pre compute all these
probability distributions and then judge
based on some confidence levels
but for those separate functions but I
still think we need something for the
first case and the main question for me
is in indeed this example shows it very
well so do computed the minimum of
something one and some and something two
something around one something around
two and we got something around 0.3
isn't it is this acceptable I find it
very weird
I think it's very weird
I I think we we have we need a criterium
to decide whether to return their their
own around around one or around two but
not around something else
I understand a notebook do we have
Sanders notes here did you put them at
the bottom here uh yeah they're in the
section right there
okay
oh
yeah so these are the the things we
could pre-compute and create these
functions
so what is this about here so this is so
for example around this having around
less with a confidence level
okay
and this could return true or false
depending on the confidence
by the way comparing just the centers is
confidence level 50 exactly
oh
is that obvious even very symmetric
distributions uh for asymmetric I didn't
think about it for symmetric is oh yes
because after probability uh well I
think for asymmetrical this must be
huh
well so what this is saying
oh gosh but we don't want to have an
around Min around this around that do we
don't know um I mean we have the
president of vector
well okay let's assess how many of these
around star functions we need to have
I mean look first point is we're not
going to be able to get away with okay
around itself
with pure less
is going to do something which hopefully
will be as sensible as possible maybe
it's the 50 confidence thing that it was
nice because we can just say 20
confidence AKA it's just taking the
centers
and then if you want to be more precise
use this thing that allows you to
specify the confidence level
we could do what equal does which is
having a variable that controls the
tolerance right foreign
we could promote it to system okay
foreign I think that's totally
horrifying just imagine somebody resets
that with a giant blob of code just
stops working
I don't think we ever want people to
reset it
is a global fact
can somebody explain the 50 thing is
that important because it's not
it's confusing to me
so if if you have at least I I'm pretty
sure for symmetric thing so if you have
two symmetric distribution that the
probability then the the first one is
less than the second one
is at least 50 if you come just compare
the centers
okay but but all right look
okay
it would be nice
okay wait a minute we've got Vector less
but we don't have Vector Min do we
um you know because it's it's not one
dimensional
well but okay but but then what about
things like ranked Min and so on for a
rounds
well I think those would have to follow
whatever Min does right I know that but
if we have a new function around Min are
we going to have an around you know
ranked Min that would be horrifying
I think the options are
to have an option for some of these
functions like Min which we haven't had
before
that specifies confidence intervals to
use for rounds
I wish there was a way of having some
kind of wrapper
or maybe even putting it into an around
that says hey if I'm compared this is
the confidence interval to use
because then you put the burden on
instead of having to have a zillion new
functions If people really care about
this they set the option inside around
to tell it I mean let's just talk about
let's just say that I mean we could have
a wrapper I think
it could be a single a random a run
compare
and then we put the function that has to
do the competition
well what do you mean but but Min has a
separate around one around two around
three
now it will be something like a run
compare of mean comma list of rounds and
then parameters
and the first argument is I mean really
messing up how Min works so and then
then when we've got a completely
different
no no no no it will be around compare it
will take their parameters it would be
around compare of mean comma list of
rounds oh I see that makes it more that
makes sense
and then we can have the confidence
that's similar to what we did for the um
uh for the thing that has correlated
errors in a round
what's that called yes so you're talking
about the vector run
no I'm talking about is it Vector around
well we have Mina round for example and
yeah yeah wrong replace I think you're
thinking about a round replace that's
what I'm thinking about yes
yes
how is this related or not to this
around compare idea
yes I mean if for example we could hold
mean of X comma y
then we could have X goes to around y
goes to around
yeah with some confidence interval
the problem is
I mean are people ever going to use this
if let's say we have a round compare
yeah sand is suggesting around resolve
and I agree that that's better than I
mean it doesn't really compare
it's some
I'm not sure resolve is quite the right
name but but um
uh
we should just still have something in
equal and mean Etc oh of course of
course it's got to do something right
we've got to have a default right
this seems like the most sensible idea
that we have something here where
now wait a minute what functions can we
support can we support an arbitrary
function in the first argument
how would we do that
don't we need some kind of weird
automatic differentiation thing to
support arbitrary functions there
um
well we are getting almost to a round
replace
for the general case this will be like a
simplified case of a round replace
yes well the the only thing is a round
replace doesn't have
ground replace has the feature that it
can have multiple occurrences of a
single around exactly it can handle
correlation but they cannot handle
confidence levels
because we put confidence levels into a
round replace
it's not obvious that one could do that
because I think the confidence levels
have to be done on a function by
function basis don't they I mean how
I agree I I don't I don't know of a
general meaning for confidence level for
a general function
well I mean is that clear or is it is it
um
that thing the first thing is a
predicate
you're saying I mean like like okay you
know what if I do this if I say to be
crazy if I do this
the heck does that mean
well no let me let me give a let me let
me make it even more crazy
I mean okay those are integer functions
so it doesn't really count
because that's overly crazy
so none not an integer function which
has that feature that it you know what
functions take reels and return
uh booleans
yeah or or same question for what
functions take intervals
yeah all right listen I think we've
I think that
we've pretty much just discussed there's
got to be some default
for
which is not remaining unevaluated for
around
less of a rounds
perhaps it's based on the centers which
we can consider 50 confidence interval
perhaps it's based on some larger
confidence interval
then for the more pedantic we're going
to have to have some separate function
this seems like a reasonable possibility
but let's inventory what first arguments
it could have
okay
and
I mean like for example it's unclear to
me what unequalm does
I guess I guess what it is is
yeah it is okay so given a confidence
interval there if I'm not mistaken you
assume those are distributions you
assume they're gaussian distributions
and you simply ask
is the you know there's a true branch
and there's a false branch and you
simply ask what's the integral of the
true Branch what's the integral of the
false Branch how do they compare with
the stated confidence interval and that
gives you the answer
all right
yep
okay
so I I think this is a pause I mean in
other words we compute we imagine that
we compute efficiently hopefully
the
yeah I mean we should be able to in
principle that first argument there
could be any
Boolean returning function
and worst cases we use transform
distribution to compute
the support for true and the support for
false there
uh am I right I mean is that right
yeah I think it's something like that
yes
is this what we want for equal though
because I think it will always be false
or the probability of two numbers being
equal
is zero
what let's imagine if you have it's
measure zero the equality if if you have
two numbers with normal distributions
then then the probability they are equal
to zero
well I actually figured out the way to
think about this I think of you have
these two probability distributions you
take the outer product of them in a
two-dimensional space and then there's
going to be a diagonal line going
through them for greater than less than
and if you take the integral of the area
versus the area oh the equal sign is
just the integral along the particular
line
which is a colorful line
so it's an integral of of of something
that's that's true on the line and and
Falls everywhere else so the line is
measure is measure zero
yeah no but I don't understand and if we
take these this picture here
what I would have expected
there's actually there's an overlap here
there's a
and that I would have expected that
integral of that overlap
right to be compared to the whole
interval integral
does that make any sense
what's that that's how I would do it too
for equality and inequality I would
check the the area of overlapping with
respect to the total so so in other
words the the probability of of them
being
of equal you would return the complement
of a probability of of them being in
some specified less or or greater
right so if they are not less or greater
than that's what you would return for
equal
sorry sorry sorry that's that's still
not true I think wait
uh no it sounds like what you're
suggesting is the integral of the
product distribution
perhaps okay listen there's some math to
do here
okay let's let's do the math and get
back to this and you know see if we can
come up with a reasonable definition
because roughly what we I mean what I
would intuitively think this meant is
I want the probability that the things
are equal
uh your point is the probability of the
things are actually equal to zero yes
[Music]
look this is a question of of this whole
patentry that people always use in
talking about statistics maybe Gosha can
help us out here
um
about you know samples and whatever I
mean we're asking the wrong question
it's it's
not our two given samples ever equal
it's some other
there's some other formulation of this
that makes more sense
well you can ask the question whether
two samples come from the same
distribution
which is not helping you here but the
other thing that comes to mind is the
the likelihood the long likelihood which
computes the the likelihood of a sample
coming from a given distribution
right which is the for the single
element it's a p it corresponds to the
PDF
I mean it's computers for the PDFs
we need some act on here we we have
questions
um
okay we've got oh I'll happily type up
some notes because I think I've have a
half of an idea what's going on here
good the other thing I'm still wondering
about is if we should be
trying to make an analogy between around
an interval because I think a lot of
this stuff is more clear what to do with
the intervals than it is with around
well we think of interval as basically
being uh you know a unit step type
function and the unit step could be
units of the standard deviation
of a round
but I I don't think around sorry
intervals is the right model here I
think numbers is the right model
for example I I just placed in the chat
and a comparison that gives true even
though the numbers are different
and I think that's what we should try to
imitate
right
and what uh what do less and graders say
there
well there's tolerance
so they may also
so let's yeah
we've got more to figure out here no
this is less than greater won't work
because of that order example that I
gave
which looks broken
all right this is a surprisingly
complicated area I mean you know in a
sense
around is trying to pack
you know
around us sort of you know it's like
everything with these statistical kinds
of things we're we're trying to pack a
lot of information into the we're trying
to say you know
this around thing is trying to pack tons
of information about an infinite
collection of measurements and so on and
it's not clear
you know we're always going to get
bitten somewhere
because it's trying to summarize
something that we don't even know what
the underlying thing is and so on
right are we going to let's take a very
quick look here so right so less and
greater give false for for that example
which would seem to contradict Jose's
claim that just looking at the centers
would be doing what numbers do
oh gosh
all right I I'm
we need to do some homework here
okay
I mean I don't think we can get further
right now
we've defined a possible Direction Let's
see whether we can make that work
and then you know and then it is my
feeling that rounds that are far away
from each other
should evaluate with less
directly and not try and be pedantic
right okay
and
you know I think somewhere we've got to
have a um
less remains unevaluated just for single
numbers right if they're too close is
that true
no for numbers they never unless
it has tolerance so so yeah exactly if
they are closed then they are not
strictly equal I think it just gives
false
yeah if if equal gives true then less
has to be false
I see I see I see I see I see
I see well let's work try and work that
through
all right I I think we should wrap up
for today here
um
and uh I don't think we're I think we've
we've set two
I don't think we're likely to be able to
um
uh
now by the way these things here
probably should become system functions
at some point they're sufficiently
commonly used it seems like they are
these distances between
distributions
Gosha seems like that should be
you know I I just see that quite often
I I think I think we should probably
wrap up for today here
okay
and thank you all very much thank you to
sander for raising this admittedly
incredibly naughty
uh issue which normally would have been
in an LCC meeting not a an ild meeting
but I guess we quite well it was
supposed to be but week uh we didn't
make it last week
okay fine
it wasn't that agenda last week yeah
okay well it was a difficult topic all
right
sounds good thanks a lot see you all
soon